for as long as we've been playing video
games we've been complaining that their
broken [__] pistol why is that
allowed
it is so broken it ain't that you drop
your net how did they think that was
okay either put it in the game so usual
this gays [__] [__] I'm gonna
spit Montgomery's [__] nose stupid
all right
so that last one might be going a little
far but for most of us complaining about
a game's balance has become almost a
daily ritual at its heart balance is a
question of fairness are the paths to
victory and defeat the same for each
player or are there shortcuts that
provide unforeseen advantages to tip the
scale in one direction and from the
earliest days of video games to today
these questions have formed a
treacherous tightrope the developers
have attempted to walk but even before
people start competing head-to-head
balance has been a subject of scrutiny
for game designers back in the 1980s
Danielle Bunton Barry an early game
designer was asked how she balanced her
games she said that she would cheat and
make the AI better and then lie about it
to the players who complained while that
[__] might have flown back then it
couldn't today especially with the power
that social media has given consumers
prior to the Internet age even if gamers
complaints were heard dad's had no
actual means of fixing issues with their
product all they could do is privately
note the criticism and attempt to
release an improved sequel but thanks
the technological innovation since then
it's no longer the case
now devs can directly engage with their
communities and remedy game problems
using quickly deployed patches and hot
fixes sweet dies
cool that's awesome at all how did it
even make it to live servers for
competitive games that have evolved into
eSports these updates have become more
and more important not only do they help
in keeping medes feeling fresh they also
help to eliminate broken strategies and
mechanics the players discover over time
banana throw a true ride on the Disney
Express welcome to the well however in
spite of all these advances bouncing
remains an endless and possible and
sometimes controversial endeavor and
with everyone happily making their
grievances known online as a developer
it's more important and difficult than
ever to attempt to address players
concerns well good luck with all that
Rainbow six siege is a daunting game to
balance from its fully destructible
environments to its 46 operators
possessing unique abilities and a
plethora of weapons it presents its fair
share of challenges and its community is
among the most outspoken [__] game
Ubisoft my god dude to get a sense of
just how difficult this whole process is
we talked to sieges director Leroy
Atanasoff about how Ubisoft Montreal
approaches such a challenge we are a lot
data-driven we use the community as
tools that help us to we have to look at
other data because obviously there is a
turn internal data every time you play
your fire your time you're at your peak
right
weapon precision and stuff like that so
we have a bunch of data and if you don't
know what you want to look at inside
it's really difficult so how exactly the
game developers know where to look for
problems among this massive sea of data
well that's where you me and the chronic
complainers of the gaming world come
into play using the community to look at
ok what has the biggest issue ok people
complain about this stuff or this stuff
is it true or not let's look at the data
so it's not like we are acting right
away on the community feedback is that
we use the community feedback to focus
on where we need to look at in terms of
data wise yes that's right even though
most of us are guilty of complaining
about anything and everything our cries
for nerfs can actually end up shaping
the games we love as long as they're
collectively loud and frequent enough
but even in cases where the data doesn't
match the community's complaints a fan
Assaf maintains that they're still
married to the criticism we had a lot of
conception issue
in glass okay a lot of people complain
about glass but if you look at the data
he's actually in a good position and the
human one is super funny the way it
works is that you tend to remember more
often things that are frustrating that
mean actually people were cleaning a lot
of glass and didn't dice that much
against glass but every time they died
against glass because it was frustrating
in the sense of they didn't feel like
they had the opportunity to do something
they tend to remember only those women
at actually have a sense of my glass is
mocha on your arm when you need to fix
it and stuff like that so it's not that
is unbalanced it is frustrating you see
what I mean and during the sex
Invitational Ubisoft finally revealed
changes to glass that aim to address
these frustrations without nerfing the
operator entirely what's happening with
glass in year four he became a bit too
good in close quarters so what we've
done is we've linked his eye our scope
to his movement we approached him to be
much more of a sniper role whether this
rework satisfies the community remains
to be seen but it's an intriguing
process to see in action but that
doesn't mean that every fan complaint is
legit sometimes people just have a hard
time accepting change look no further
than the introduction of elemental
Drake's in League of Legends a change
which pissed off nearly everyone when it
was announced but arguably ended up
adding strategic depth to the game I
think Donald rake is perfect for a team
that wants to split push with that
trundle mousses that's up as well but
every once in a while a developer will
[__] up on such a monumental scale that
their abominations end up in the score
eSports Museum of busted [__] behold the
amazing wonder of league of legends 2012
off-season Black Cleaver meta not to be
a ridiculed CS goes 2015 r8 revolver and
who could forget
Blackbeard's virtually unbreakable
shield from 2016 now we wanted to test
what the chalk is machine gun would do
it to it
that just makes no [__] sense but on
top of balancing a game's fairness and
fun factor there's another obstacle that
those with eSports scenes have to
overcome finding a compromise between
Pro and casual play pros aren't really
playing the same game you are at home
sure it looks similar but they're more
skilled and coordinated than you and
you're for drunk buddies running a
recruit rush ever will be nope in an
operator like castle who is also primed
for a rework in 2019 highlights the
divide between those two player groups
perfectly at eye level colleague level
especially yes some music you know like
I think it's a good position you know
like depending on the map depending on
the height eg you can totally play the
castle and it will be a variable option
and include something very interesting
to the team but aside of that for the
rest of the population that is beings
again cassadee's we use this even though
it's clear that sieges balance leans
towards a more casual audience with its
consistent content flow there are
concerns that the constant additions to
the roster are only creating more
balancing challenges down the road so
we're the biggest limiting factors for
siege is the confidence upward momentum
with operators we keep adding layers to
the game to the point at which
countering those layers becomes a bit
redundant I would like to find an even
ground where we can start balancing
around that even ground I don't see that
as very likely and I again I believe I'm
very much in the minority with the way
that this this works I I think most
people are really okay with the the
content stream I think on a casual level
it really helps the game but ya know
it's always gonna it's always gonna drag
down the eSports which isn't the end of
the world for some people I am happy
that I have nothing to do with making
decisions in terms of balancing does
that seems like almost an impossible
impossible job but is it truly
impossible is a perfectly balanced game
really just a pipe dream
I think nexif perfect balance is a no
reason you know it's some things that
you're aiming for and it's by aiming for
it's that you're constantly shifting the
meta and makes the game interesting and
good for I want 200 but we will never
each point well it should be I don't
we'll be at the same peak Heights same
we like it's impossible
while the perfectly balanced game might
never be made there's no question that
over the last 20 years we've gotten a
lot closer to that ideal and as long as
developers continue to collaborate with
their passionate communities our
experiences of the games that we love
will only continue to improve because of
it man balance is so important
I haven't played overwatch in months
because of goats Matt you are way too
excited about farm animals you know so
worse when people blink too much I'm
like very like conscious of not what I'm
sorry yeah in the history of eSports
certain highlights transcend others like
strobe lights very horrific